looking ahead to 2020 one reason why i'm
taking you seriously as a contender
is because of your presence on cable
news i don't think you seem that creepy
but
but that's just me it's because you're
both creepy you jackass
and he just got 30 months in jail how's
that for reliable sources
what a thursday we've got quite a panel
here this evening
look who's joined us jesse waters
he's our favorite man on the street but
sometimes we wish we'd left him there
his hair is like an extension cord thick
dark and full of plugs
oh yes but he's here tonight it's
amazing what you'll do when you're
trying to sell a book
true he tried to sell me one in the
bathroom
but hey when you got mouths to feed and
massages to get above a bodega on ninth
avenue and he poured into storm
but at least you wrote your book unlike
killmead
you know who wrote his right
but jesse's book is a wild success
finally giving him
one that he could point to in his life
other than lettering and lacrosse at
devry
then there's dana perino there she is
i can i can never remember if she has a
dog or not
but to her credit she's capping a long
day of work from 9 00 a.m
to midnight tonight god how lucky is her
husband
no peter take out the garbage no peter
wipe your feet
no peter that's jasper's chair
[Laughter]
can you imagine what peter's doing
tonight right now when she's not home
[Applause]
he's very proud of that evening and god
only knows what jasper's doing
when you're not there dana
at least he wiped jasper's been on fox
so many times maybe you should host fox
news prime time
i mean have you seen some of the scrubs
they have on there
also on the show tonight david asman
charles payne cancelled
i kid i kid asmin is a regular over at
fox business
you know how they have mornings with
maria well they were planning on
evenings with asmin
but the title was just one s away from a
movie i made in tijuana
but look dana and jesse are here tonight
because it's
the 10th anniversary of the five
to put it in language that cat
understands that's 10 years
or the answer her husband gives when
asked what it feels like to be married
to cat for three months
it's a big deal because like brian
stelter without a training bra
surviving 10 years in cable isn't normal
i just want you to think about that
image mtv didn't even play music that
long
the five is like one of those super old
japanese ladies they find out that just
turned 120 years old
and everybody wants to know her secret
and it turns out she can't count
but think of all the things the five
oh thank you i don't know if that's a
good thing but think of all the stuff
that the five out lasted
kangaroos hummingbirds
green frogs koala bears
hedgehogs yep the five beat all their
average
life spans i guess you could say animals
are great
but the five is greater but we also beat
these
shows a whole bunch of them yeah in your
face will and grace
seriously who expected a reboot of that
to work what's next
you know let's reboot kovid deborah
messing could play the delta variant
yeah we outlasted shows with bigger
budgets bigger staffs and better drugs
at fox we're lucky if we can snort
crushed up a leave in the green room
bathroom
i learned that trick from stuart varney
no so why do the five succeed it's not
rocket science
or in jesse's case simple arithmetic
but in case you need a refresher of how
great the five is
here's a montage
uh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i want to get greg in here greg greg
greg is intrigued all right greg
take us home greg go greg greg dare i
say greg
greg greg greg greg i'm coming to you
next greg thank you greg
you're welcome greg greg greg let's go
greg
greg greg greg so let's bring in our
constitutional scholar greg gutfeld
greg greg greg i'm glad that we're we're
friends again greg
greg right greg greg greg thank you greg
how many how many women does that guy
get
okay identify as women but there's a
very unique role that the five plays
today it's a live show in which people
speak their minds
which is as dangerous these days as
walking a tightrope between two
skyscrapers and heels basted in butter
we are and have been at the forefront of
cancer culture we saw it coming because
it came to us
early on in this day and age there's a
cottage industry based on the dopamine
hit
one gets from attacking strangers it's a
potshot theater on twitter where people
wait to pounce on us for saying
something honest because honesty is what
gets you in trouble
you don't ever notice that cnn msnbc abc
cbs nbc anchors
they never get into trouble i mean with
their pants on
and even while the late night shows kept
quiet about it we didn't we took it on
and we keep at it every day we show up
and none of us bite our tongues except
maybe dana
you should hear her profanity-laced
rants about immigrants in the green room
i had no idea there were so many curse
words that rhymed with guatemalans
but the reason for the five success and
fox's success and this show's success is
risk
we are taking a risk every day to tell
you the truth and when the truth is
especially under fire we're the first
responders to bullsh
and it's a tribute to the audience who
support us
but it's so predictable how the media
reacts to new fox shows
it happened with the 5 10 years ago and
it happens with this show today
the recipe is always the same a press
release announces the show
haters tune in to trash it they write
about the stuff they don't like which
ironically is the same things the fans
love about it
and then the haters go away and the fans
stay and the show becomes a hit
and it runs for thousands of episodes
repeat
so tonight our first block is dedicated
to the five and everyone who contributed
to its success
including you the viewers who keep me
employed
and in silk stockings
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
reaches for the stars but she'll be
lucky to reach the shelf
america's newsroom co-anchor and the
five coaster
the burrito
he never joined a frat he is the frat
the five co-hosts and watterswell host
jesse waters
he's spent a decade as a journalist but
we won't hold that against him
fox business anchor david asman
[Music]
and for her wedding she registered at
bed bath and a bong
fox news contributor cat tip
dana we are all wearing our special five
jerseys
right suit up yeah she looks good in
hers oh david you know what that's
sexist okay
yeah how come i didn't get one that
those two times that i filled in
in the christmas week of 2015.
pretty pivotal right i think i had
something to do with the success
two times christmas week the ratings
were really strong
for me but i think dana it's got to be
tough for you to come into work every
day and still be
star struck when you're around me how do
you maintain
the composure when you come to work
because it's like you never get
too difficult it's very i actually uh
pinch myself so that the pain
takes away the fear that's that's the
way to do it but my wife
wonders where i've been all day when she
sees my black and blue mark
i'd say for me it's been um
it's been amazing to be a part of the
show as jessie
begins his career and yours is coming to
an end
oh nice dana that's stung
i'm not gonna lie jesse if it weren't
for the five you'd probably be living in
a youth hostel
i thought he did yes turning tricks for
your next fix
oh jeez glad you asked me about my book
greg
because in the book i wrote about some
of the things you say
in the commercial break and i'd like to
share these things with the audience
all right get the bleeper ready i hate
the ocean
[Laughter]
real quote charity sucks it's the best
thing you'll ever do and they get all
the money
if you're going to kill your spouse take
them hiking
wow i know it's true and it's true
it's the best way and then the cheapest
form of phone sex
is to call victoria's secret and ask
them to go through the catalog with you
wow
i'm going to read the last one when you
buy drugs on a friday you can't do them
all that night
you have to save some for sunday brunch
so if you want to hear more about what
greg says in the commercial break by
how i save the world and get it on
amazon because reese witherspoon is
beating me right now
and nothing against reese but i heard
the last book she recommended made
everyone sick
but she wrote her book oh
i don't know that's those are fighting
words yeah so kat uh
you yes you do have some experience with
that
um um care to add anything to this self
congratulations party yeah i was gonna
say i'm also it's a little bit like high
school when
everyone's talking about how much fun
they had the parties that i wasn't
invited to
um but you know i i'm a viewer i enjoy
the show i'm very
you know happy for all of you and i'm
excited that also this show that was
supposed to not go on very long and
everyone was
saying was cancelled after like three
episodes is doing very well
yeah let's be honest if if it wasn't for
the five
you probably never would have met your
husband right
i don't know how that makes sense we met
on an app
[Laughter]
do you make everything up yes greg
how how did you get your staff
to make that montage of all the things
about you i mean
she wants one yeah i said i said at the
starting
you know what would really upset dana is
if we did a montage and it was
just me and in the middle of the montage
you said
i've had it i i was just like how long
is this thing going to go on
yes but i mean you were the one that
started a podcast called the one
yes that's right i thought it gave me
some great ideas for my weekend show
we're going to do that on saturday night
except all me
yes yes hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else